تحرم فيفا لمسه كاس العالم الا على اشخاص
معينين وهم الفائزون الحاليون به او
السابقون كذلك زعماء الدول لهذه الكاس
سيره طويله واسطوريه بدات قبل نحو 92 عاما
كاس النصر كان الاسم الاول لكاس العالم
الذي حمله معه رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم فيفا جول ريميان من فرنسا الى
الاوروغواي في اول بطوله اجريت هناك وفازت
بها الدوله المستضيفه الكاس الغاليه على
عشاق الكره انتقلت من اسمها الاول الى
الاسم الجديد
تكريما للرجل الذي امن بفكره بطوله عالميه
تجمع اعظم اللاعبين ليكون اسمه عليها بدءا
من كاس العالم عام 1950 في البرازيل في
عام
1974 تم استبداله كاس جوندريادي اخر صممه
الايطالي سيلفو جانا ليكون نسخه جديده ما
زالت حتى اليوم تحافظ على القها كل اربع
سنوات ويشتاق لها محبو البطوله هذه الكاس
الشهيره اصبحت بعد سنوات ترمم بيد رجل
عربي مغربي اسمه احمد ايه تسيلي الذي ساهم
في عمليه صيانتها في اخر خمس بطولات
عالميه